the war words heating up between Anthony
spero Moochie and President Trump after
criticizing Trump's visit to El Paso the
moods now launching even more attacked
on his former boss I think you have to
consider a change at the top of the
ticket when someone is acting like this
he has a nihilistic way to his
personality so the minute you say
something he doesn't like he he figures
that he can intimidate you like a bully
there's a pernicious evil in trying to
divide the country and of course Trump
hit him back and mocking scare moves his
11 days in the White House Trump also
tweeted scare Moochie who like so many
others had nothing to do with my
election victory has only upset that I
didn't want him back in the
administration where he desperately
wanted to be also I said him had many
time had time to return his many calls
to me he just wanted to be on TV so now
he is on TV yes so I've talked to scare
Moochie he told me that one of the
things that he's upset about is the
criticism that go back to this but do
you think there's more to it I don't
know I mean this is these are these are
both people that are quite likeable when
you see him on TV I'm talking about
Trump and Ciara Moochie kind of like
listening to them the the mooch was not
for Trump in 2016 and then he was for
Trump now he's not for Trump I don't
know what to make of that except
possibly it's sincere I believe that
they could potentially patch things up
with in the next six months or so and
won't that be a reunion can I point out
the skirmish she has also suggested that
perhaps the Republicans will need to
replace them in 2020 and do you know who
scaramouche II followed today on Twitter
Mark Sanford former Republican
congressman from South Carolina who is
primary so I don't think he could win
that but Gregg mm-hmm since he made that
tweet now saying the 2020 challenge that
that end them getting back together
right there yeah it's a pretty
I think the Real Housewives thing didn't
pan out and scary Buchi got the got the
bug he got the film bug that money can't
the mud that the spotlight bug that the
money can't satisfy he's
a meerkat he's good when he sees the
spotlight you know how the meerkats just
pick up that's that's the mooch I have a
sports analogy okay but most of you will
not get it except for one because we're
close I get it Donald Trump is the Al
Davis of presidents Al Davis ran the
Oakland Raiders in the 1970s he had a
single motto motto which was just win
baby didn't care how he attracted rough
scary and weird people that was the
entire Oakland Raiders they were just
people and so you also get these weird
third stringers they scare Moochie and
amaurosis not the best judgment calls on
on Trump's part but they get in on this
under the guise of loyalty and then it
doesn't work out they turn on you and
that's another game he's like he's like
amorosa to exact you know I was thinking
this early because I only the best
people by the way yes is the one who
said he was a narcissist and a racist
and then he called her a lowlife a dog
and Rex Tillerson who I don't think he
is he's exactly lowlife but I think Rex
Tillerson said he was a [ __ ] right and
you get you keep going of what they
these insights so my take on this is
this is where Morris this is buyer's
remorse for people who wanted to get in
on the power deal wanted to get to visit
the White House wanted that big title
the important job together and
scaramouche II well they all got the job
but at some point like they're like you
know maybe this wasn't a good idea and
scaramouche II what's interesting and he
got fired for doing like that stupid
drunken phone call for leakage so what
I'm saying drunken not saying what I
really think he's on if what you're
saying now is true why wasn't it true
before you took after Mexico because I
think you thought that he could help
right he was gonna go no that's what
that's what Tillerson in here Sierra
Lucchese point is that Trump turned on
him not scared lucha turned on truck
call the truth want to needs attention
yeah and so it is very chilly quite cold
in the
when you're being ignored by the media
how do you should get that big ray of
sunshine to shine on you from President
Trump president Trump took the bait
he absolutely took the bait and fired
back at him immediately I'll point this
out Anthony scaramouche II supported
Obama in 2008 he went to law school with
him he contributed to the campaign then
he flipped and supported Mitt Romney he
hated on President Trump and then he
supported him and he's got his finger in
the air and he's trying to figure out
which way the wind is blowing and
remember Steve Ross big developer you
know all the arrows were being fired at
him in the last week week and a half
there you go